good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I
have strep throat which I read zero out
of ten not recommended so your video
about the political situation in Brazil
made me think about the political
situation here in the United States
specifically the tortuously long Kafka s
process through which the two major
political parties in the United States
determine their nominees for president
delving deeply into the whole sordid
affair would take like a month so today
we're just going to look at one state
Missouri last week the people of
Missouri voted in their presidential
primaries and on the Republican side
Donald Trump beat Ted Cruz statewide by
about point one nine percent and on the
Democratic side Hillary Clinton beat
Bernie Sanders by a similar margin but
what actually matters for becoming your
party's nominee is not how many votes
you get but how many delegates are
pledged to you because the nominees are
not actually chosen by voters they are
chosen by delegates at the party's
national conventions in July the
Republicans are meeting in Cleveland the
Democrats in Philadelphia on the
Republican side there will be twenty
four hundred seventy three of these
delegates voting at the convention and
on the Democratic side there will be
four thousand seven hundred sixty-five
ish it depends a little bit on if
anybody dies right so despite only
winning the statewide primary by 0.2
percent Hillary Clinton emerged from
Missouri with 47 delegates to Bernie
Sanders 35 in fact she would have won
more delegates than Sanders even if she
lost by 0.2 percent because the Missouri
Democratic Party has named 13 so-called
super-delegates who can support whomever
they want at the convention and most of
them have endorsed Clinton Missouri
super-delegates include the state's
governor jay Nixon Senator Claire
McCaskill and like other prominent
members of the state's Democratic Party
then there are the 71 delegates who
actually represent Missouri's Democratic
primary voters by say party rule their
votes are split proportionately
according to the results so if Clint had
gotten a hundred percent of the vote she
would have gotten all 71 delegates but
she just barely beat Sanders so instead
she got 36 delegates to his 35 this year
in Missouri there were about eighty
eight hundred Democratic votes for each
of these 71 pledged delegates which
means that at the party's convention in
Philadelphia governor jay Nixon will
have you know around eighty eight
hundred times more power than the
average Democratic voter in Missouri and
not to belabor the obvious or anything
that's not a power distribution
generally associated with the word
democracy but wait there's more over on
the Republican side Donald Trump beat
Ted Cruz very narrowly statewide but
emerged with 37 delegates to Cruz's 15
and John Kasich who
10% of the vote won no delegates at all
but it wasn't all bad news for Kasich
because on the same day in Ohio he got
47% of the Republican vote but all of
the state 66 delegates that's because
the rules of the Republican state party
in Ohio dictate that whoever gets the
most votes gets all the delegates
whereas the rules created by the state
party in Missouri dictate that if no one
gets 50% the winner gets 12 delegates
and then five delegates go to the winner
of each of Missouri's eight
congressional districts Trump won the
state and five of the congressional
districts ergo 37 delegates sorry that's
going to get a little complicated bit of
context for non-americans there are 435
congressional districts in the United
States each of these districts elects a
congress person every two years who goes
to Washington and fails to pass a budget
presumably they also do other things but
the main thing is to make sure that we
don't accidentally pass a budget each
state gets a certain number of
congressional districts based on their
population and after the 2010 census it
was determined that a smaller percentage
of Americans lived in Missouri so they
lost a congressional district while fast
growing states like Arizona in Florida
gained districts but this was in a
district offered the state of Missouri
an opportunity to redraw its
congressional boundaries back in 2010
there were six congressional districts
represented by Republicans and three
represented by Democrats if one of those
had to go the Republicans obviously
wanted it to be a majority democratic
district which is what happened because
one they controlled the state
legislature and to one of the Democratic
Congress people helped them because in
that process his district became even
more democratic you know now he's less
likely to lose his job today
congressional districts in Missouri are
drawn mostly in a way that makes the
elections within them extremely lopsided
like in 2014 the first congressional
district in Missouri voted 73 percent to
21 percent for the Democrat the third
district meanwhile voted 68 percent to
27 percent for the Republican et cetera
but for Republican state party rules no
matter which district you win you get
the same five delegates like in
Missouri's first congressional district
about 34,000 republican votes were cast
in the seventh district it was closer to
150,000 so just by virtue of living in
the first district instead of the
seventh your Republican primary vote is
five times more powerful in short and
all of this is extremely complicated and
none of it is particularly democratic at
least not in the straightforward way we
usually imagine democracy political
parties are weird institutions in the
United States like they're
simultaneously public organizations and
private clubs they make their own rules
the rules are constantly changing but in
many cases
the rules are regulated by the states
and political parties are powerful but
only insofar as their supporters allow
them to have power also they don't
really have card-carrying members but
almost every nationally elected figure
belongs to one of them now some of this
is a legacy from a time when the United
States was openly suspicious of what we
now call voting rights I mean for most
of American history and most adults
couldn't vote and political parties
served partly as a check against
revolution or radical change in fact the
nominating process has become much more
democratic over time like as recently as
1968 only 34 percent of Republican
delegates were chosen by primaries and
only 38 percent of Democratic delegates
and for the last ten election cycles in
both parties the person with the most
overall primary and caucus support has
also been the eventual nominee but that
may not be the case this year and it
remains to be seen who will actually
wield the power when the party and the
people disagree Hank I'll see you on
Friday